uh i know why you're happy and probably
at home we've reached 100 days of the
biden administration it's like
it's like uh
it's like america was a three-month
juice cleanse i i
i feel so much lighter i i mean it's
amazing how much trump was in there
and yeah
and uh joe celebrated with his favorite
beer old malarkey
[Applause]
but he's got a lot to celebrate the
economy is surging
uh growth 6.4 percent now of course a
lot of this because we were stuck last
year but even for any time
in one quarter 6.4 this is
this is fox news's worst nightmare
they convince everybody biden is a
socialist and then
oh [ __ ] it's working
to give you an idea how rapidly this
economy is moving
take a chart of the oscar ratings and
turn it upside down
it just oh yeah very low uh
oh sad
10 million people it used to get like
super bowl numbers
10 million like this show's gotten
almost half of that
this one and one of the winners
you know went up there and did that
thing they always do we thanked his
agent and god and then told his kids and
and go to bed kids and the babies that
are texted back they already did
and nobody liked this show
but the economists say the surge in the
economy is driven by
you people the the consumer ladies and
gentlemen
people are spending spending
it's like we're all strippers and the
government made it rain
and now we can't wait to hit jimmy choos
you know i mean it's
and i i i i can see it i'm
on the drive in today i saw a packed car
dealership
i saw a long line for an open house and
there were two people at sears
so cruel but
you know i tried to give a panhandler
five bucks a day and he told me to make
a more serious offer
i tell you
but uh joe did you see his speech he
gave us what really is the state of the
union speeches first one did you watch
not you people up well you did okay well
i thought he was good i mean he hadn't
been a member of congress since 2008 a
lot of new faces
a lot of new names he thought aoc was
the active ingredient in weed
but it did pretty well 22 million people
watched uh it's interesting the older
democrats uh
saw it on tv the millennials watched it
on their phone
and the q a they can't even the q anon
folks
listen to it over the 5g in their
vaccine
oh yes by the way the speech very
coveted safe
joe's speech oh yes the big question
people had was
should we stay six feet away from ted
cruz or
an additional six feet to the six feet
we'd normally have been spending away
i get ted ted did you ten groups during
the speech fell asleep
they caught him of course you know ted
the liar he said he wasn't asleep he was
protesting wokeness
ridiculous oh yeah they're
the republicans they were not happy with
joe's speech he gave he did not give the
speech they wanted him to make
so they were pissed off ted was pissed
he lauren bobert you know this
nut one of the new republicans in
congress from colorado
oh wow this is a loon like on a marjory
taylor green level
during the speech this she dramatically
unfurled one of those mylar blankets you
know those kids in cage
silver blankets i i don't even really
know
the point of this
[Applause]
protest i i get so i'm just going to
take the high road
and say everybody's entitled their
opinion but do not ask me ever to
respect prop comedy
what does that even mean mylar blanket
but yeah maybe she was pissed about
masks it was like i say a very covered
safe uh
speech a minimal audience um mandatory
mass
everybody's spaced apart you know what
it was a lot like what we do here
except joe's new rules cost two trillion
each
that's oh yeah
it was uh
he talked a lot about money what we
spent what we're going to spend 2
trillion
he talked about that we've already spent
for covert relief and then another two
trillion he wants for infrastructure
and then he's got a family's plan uh
another two trillion the entire federal
budget is four trillion and this is on
top of that
boy thank god we got mexico to pay for
that wall huh
uh
and uh i don't know
i'm sure a lot of americans are saying
you know what if you put the democrats
in charge they spend all your money
and if you put trump in charge you get a
disease
it's like having to choose between
marriage and dating
you